[Music]
there's two of these cars on the planet
one of them's in Europe we probably
don't need to say on the planet you've
probably just say two of these cars
right cuz you wouldn't go well what plan
are we talking about it lecture one on
Mars or is one on the moon like I'm Matt
D'Andrea and this is car collectors hey
I'm Adam Carolla welcome to Corolla
digital you want to see some cars my god
so come on my name is Adam Carolla I do
a podcast I'm a comedian and I race
vintage car
[Music]
this car is probably worth $800,000
depending on who's drunk I didn't get
into this hobby to make money I got into
it because of the beauty of the
sculpture I mean it really is work art
but you know so much got a big fat check
that drunk never to find me Adam Carolla
thank you for inviting us to your studio
here we have your Paul Newman race car Y
collecting Paul Newman cars I started
reading up on Newman and kind of
investigating the kind of guy was he's
won a bunch of championships driving a
car I mean this guy is an incredible guy
you know so I was like I'm buying his
cars and yeah I'm gonna race
so that's write it up I like Frankie
Muniz his race car and you have one for
sale I don't know you buy it I saw him
at barrett-jackson a fool call everybody
asks about the color combination kind of
looks very Christmasy
it's an aston martin british nut British
racing green but Aston Martin Racing
green which is different than British
racing green
there's old British cars it had that red
leather interior on the green and I was
like that's awesome combo I do think a
car supposed to be in its colour like a
big bulbous beautiful Brazilian ass that
were pasty white wouldn't look good
tell me what you did to the engine on
this car well the car comes with big fat
ugly air filters on it it's like taking
a super model and put a Berk on them I
took off the big air filters I mean they
look like medicine cabinets you know it
hides the work art do I found these tea
strainers and they turned out to be the
right size this is a Corolla only item
I'm sure you've raced this one quite a
bit as well
tell me about Jim Fitzgerald who who had
this car fitzy as he was known was a
really good driver and him and Newman
worked out nicely together as his
driving partner fitzy didn't know
anything about Hollywood or movies or
anything so he just like racing cars
yeah they made a perfect team Adam thank
you so much for inviting us here
anything for you man
and I hope you guys enjoyed this
subscribe to GQ send us your comments
let us know what you want to see on car
collectors
[Music]